よろしくお願いします
今日はアンブリマーラというスッタだそうです
アルンダカラン エーワンメーすたんえかんさまやんばがわさわっりやん
ウィアレティジェータワネアナートピンディカッスアーラメ
それからお釈迦様がこのジェータワナというお寺で住んでいた時の話です
アナートピンディカさんの寺で
テーナコーパナサメーナランヨーパセーナディッサコーサラッサヴィジテーチョーローアンクリマーローナマホーティ
ルッドーローヒタパーニハタパハテーニヴィットーアダアダヤアダヤパンノーパーナブーテースー
テーナコーパナサメーナソノートキ
ランヨーパセーパセーナディッサコーサラッサパセーナディコーサラッというおさまに
ビジテー国で チョーローアンクリマーロー
アンクリマーラというまあ
チョーローっていうのは泥棒ということなんですけどね
ナマホーティアンクリマーラという名前の泥棒がいたんだと
ルッドー まあとても 何でしたっけ
ルッデっていうのはこの恐ろしいっていうかね
決して優しくはないというこの言葉の反対の言葉なんですね
ローヒタパーニっていうのは
手は血何でしたっけ 血の
次の言葉はこのハタパハテー
まあ殺すことに明け暮れているというね
殺すことにニビッと まあそればっかりやってるんですね
それに 人を殺すことに明け暮れている
アダヤアダヤパンノ うんとまあ
優しさっていうのは全くもない
パーナブーテス生き物に対して
そういうような泥棒がいたんだと
テーネガーマアピアガマーカタ
彼が ガーマーっていうのは村のこと
村はアガマーカタ まあ村でなくなったっていうことにしましたといわゆる村ごとに壊すということなんですね
ニガマーっていうのは村より大きいところなんですね
村いくつかまとめたらニガマと呼ぶんですね
こんなもう それでもアニガマーカタ
全く全部もう壊して潰して人を殺して
もうもう人がいないところで閉じ込まっちゃうんですね
ジャナパダ まあジャナパダといえば地方という意味なんですね
県みたいなもんで 県一つでも全部アジャナパダカタもう全部なくなっちゃうんだと
人がいなくなって逃げて
この人来て来て殺すんだから
みんな逃げてしまうっていうことなんですね
そう マヌッセワディットワワディットワアンクリマアンクリナンマーランダーレーティ
そう 彼がマヌッセ 人間をワディットワワディットワ
殺して殺して アンクリナン
指のマーラン 首輪ですね
指でできている首輪をダーレーティ
まあかけているんだ だから首に首輪かけてますね
その首輪はもう全部自分が殺した人間の指なんですね
そこでなんで指の首輪を持ってるかっていうところに注釈書の話があるんです
なんで首の指輪がつけてるんでしょうかというと
この あれですね 自分の先生の言葉を真面目に守ってやってるんだと
そのストーリーはこのようなものであると
アヤンキラコーサラランニョプローヒタッサマンターニアナマブラームニアクッチスミンパティサンディンアッガヘーシ
ブラームニアラッティバゲーガッバブッダナンアホーセ
そこでこの コーサラランニョ
コーサラ王様のプローヒタという言葉がございます
この昔の王様たちに この
あらゆることを教えてくれる
この指導してくれる大臣の格なんですけども
かなり大臣よりも普通の大臣よりも結構立場が上なんですね
指導者がいるんですよ
王の指導者だから だいたい王様はそれなりのすごい責任
知識人を選ぶんですね
まあほとんどの場合は王様より年上の先輩の誰かなんですよ
ほとんどブラマン人なんですけどね
だからこれはパーリ語でプローヒタと読むんですね
アドバイザーっていう意味なんですね
ですから 王様が何か問題あったら何かやらなくちゃいかん場合は
この人に聞いてみるんですね
どうすればいいんでしょうかと
そこでその人は全部こういう風にしてくださいとアドバイスをする
それで王様の命令なんかは
実行するのは大臣のグループがいますからね
各仕事に分けて だから
大臣たちの場合は 王が命令するだけであって
時々大臣を集めてアドバイス聞く場合もありますけど
でも仕事柄は大臣たちは王の命令を聞くということになってるんですね
王はもう自分でどうすればいいかとわからなくなっちゃうと
誰が先輩の そういうか年上の大変な学問的な能力ある政治能力ある
あらゆる学問身についているもう先生一人
年上の一人をもう一人二人か何人か
すごい頭のいい誰かいるんだったらどうせ選ばれますからね
そういうふうにあります
その人から それをプロヒタと言うんですね
そのプロヒタさんの奥さん名前マンターニー
マンターニーって奥さんが妊娠して夜出産するんですね
タッサーマートプッチとニッカマナカーレサカラナガーレアウダーニパッジャリンス
タッサーマートプッチと彼女のお腹からこのニッカマナカーレ出る時
この子供が外へ出る時
出産する時 サカラナガーレ全部町の中にあったアウダン刃物はあらゆる刃物
アウダっていうのは刃物だけではなくて
武器とかね 何でも入りますけど
パッジャリンス 光ってしまったと
子供は夜生まれというし
夜子供が生まれるその瞬間で
その王様の住んでる都会町ですから
町の中にあらゆる刃物やら
もうなんだかんだでね
もう全部いきなり光ってしまったんですね
ピカッ ランニョーマンガラコントーピサカッターネタピタアシリッティーピパッジャリ
この王様が王として持っているこの正式的な武器があるんですね
それ人を殺すためにあるんじゃなくて
王の武器として 王っていうのは軍隊の司令官ですからね
だから刀やらいろいろ他の軍事の人々の持っている武器っていうのは
王も持ってはいます それは形式的なものでも
かなり金銀宝石いろいろ入れて作っているもので
実際に戦争に使うわけじゃないんですね
それで王様がの王位を象徴するこのコンタっていうのは
この槍 何て言いますかね
人を刺すあれ 槍でしょう
おそらく わからない こうやって刺すものがあるんですね
かなり棒が長くて 遠くところでそうやって投げて刺すこともできるし
ただそういう 槍と言うかもしれません
日本語ではわからない
大きな棒の先に何かこうやって刃物できちゃって
そんなもんなんですね
それなんかそんなそれが特別に大きなものがありまして
言葉はわからない 一応槍ですね
その槍 それもすごく光ってしまったんですね
それで王様のすごい長い刀というかね
それもありますね それはもうちゃんと大事に置いておくもので
それももうだいたい王様がいるところで置いておくんですね
それも光ってしまったと
そこまで そこでこのバラモン人が夜だから家にいるんですね
家で自分の奥さんが出産するでしょうし
出産すると必ずこのあれは占いというかホラスコープというかね
それ作らなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そこでその生まれた瞬間で
このバラモン人がもう専門プロ中プロだからね
王様のカウンセリングというかね
まあキングスコンサルト
英語で言うんですけど
このプロフェッショナルとして仕事やってますけどね
だからもう彼が外に出て
空を見て 星の位置を いろんな星差の位置を計算してみた
見てみたんですね そしたら困ったもんで
チョーレナッカッテーナジャートーティ
まあ犯罪者が生まれる
星の組み合わせではないかと
星差の組み合わせはね
見たらこんな組み合わせの時は生まれる子供っていうのはもう大泥棒になるんだと
犯罪者になるんだよと
とわかったんですね でも朝ランニョサンティカンカッタ
まあ朝何のことなかったような感じで
宮殿に行って王様のお世話に行くんだから
王様にお元気ですか？とかね
夜ちゃんとお休みになられたんでしょうか？と王様に挨拶するんですね
ラージャクトーメンアーチャリヤソカセイヤ
王様 先生 私はどうやってよく眠れるんですか？と王様文句を言うんですね
ですから この顧問の人にも一応先生って呼ぶんですよ
王様よりは結構年上の目上の人なんですね
どうやって寝られるんですかと
マイハンマンガラウダンパッジャリ
私のこのマンガラウダ
このというのは この王位を示すこの特別な武器
そういうのはもう大変聖なるものみたいに大事にする
これが光ってしまったと
刀やら槍やら またいくつあるでしょうね
その夜いきなり突然パッと光ってしまったと
昼だったら何か太陽の光で何でもあったのではないかと思いませんか？ですけど
これも夜だからね それで王様が怖くなって
ラッジャッサワージーヴィタッサワーアントラーヨーバヴィッサティマンジェ
私は思うには 私の国に何か大変な危険が訪れる
あるいは私の命がなくなる
自分が暗殺されるか 国が滅びるとか
何かに何かが起こるんだよと
そこでこの先生が言うんです
マバーイマハラージ  あまり心配しないでくださいと
マイアンガレクマロジャと
うちの子供が生まれたんだ
自分の家で タッサアヌバーヴェーナ
彼の力で 彼がかなりもう力を持って生まれたということで
彼の力で その生まれた瞬間で
王様の宮殿のだけじゃなくて
あるそれだけじゃなくてね
全ての刃物はね その瞬間で光ったんだよと
王様の形式的な武器だけじゃないんだよと
全部光ったんだよと そこで王様がそんなに力あるんですから
じゃあ将来どうなるんですかと
あなたの息子は もう大犯罪者になるんだ
とんでもない恐ろしい犯罪者になるんだよと
でもやっぱり王様はもう自分の先生だからね
もうかなりそこら辺は遠慮するんですよ
そこで キンエーカチョーロコウダフラッジャドゥーサコチョーロ
じゃあこの大犯罪者が一人で犯罪を起こす人か
あるいはグループを作って国に
あの 何て言いますか 暴動を起こすというかね
反乱を起こす そういうテロみたいなね
そういう人になるんでしょうか？と聞くんですね
だから国に対して反乱を起こすためには一人ではできません
それで自分の仲間を作らないと
一人で人殺ししたりする場合は
それはただの犯罪者でね
そこでこのバラモン人が彼はこのエーカチョーロコ
一人で犯罪を起こす泥棒になるんだと
それでいて このバラモン人が王様にね
まあ王様は好きなようにしてくださいと
父親も諦めてるんですよ
もう占いの方がもう確実で
だから正直に言って これがもういい人間のなりっこはないんだと
将来は大変な犯罪者になる
人殺しになる まあまあ一人で人殺しになるんだって
別にテロのグループを作って
そうやって何々さんみたいにっていうことはないっていうことでね
そこで王様に一応任せたんですよ
あんた好きなようにしてくださいと
やっぱり王様が自分の先生だから
まあもう何もやりたくはないんですね
ええかちょええか長六様の金カリセティ
ただの一人の泥棒はね
何ができるんですかと
国がこうされるんだから
ものすごい大きい国でしょうし
カリーササラッサッケッテエカンサーリシーサンウィアホーティ
まあ何万坪も広げるすごいこの畑で
1本のちょっとした一つの
あのちょっと米にならない同じ米と同じ形の植物があるんですよ
そういう稲あります 稲と全く同じ同じ
稲がちゃんと実る時はその金も実っちゃうんですよ
形も同じ でも食べられない
硬いんですね 種は それでまた次に種まく場合は
これも自分も一緒にまいてもらっちゃうんだからね
だからこの種のもみなんかはね
もう大事に保管するでしょうね
それをもう大事に保管して
次の年またまく ですから
余計な雑草の種も中に入ってはいるんですね
それをもう分けることはできない
それで米とまた一緒にということで
何万坪もかなりバカでかい大きなこの田んぼで 1本だけあったってもね
大したことないという感じで
それで王様がそんなもうあまり気にせんでもいいやと
子供育てなさいと 王様が子供育てるように言うんですよ
あんた気にする必要ない
あんたの子はね すごい殺人者になったっても
まあ国には何も国に国には問題ないんだったらね
それはその時のことで
ですから せっかくの子供だから育てなさいと
いろいろ学問的な論文
このストーリーについて一応出てますけどね
私はあんまり勉強してないんだからね
そこら辺皆様ご意見あるんだったら言ってください
この注釈書の言葉についてもいろいろまあ意訳あったり
疑問があったり これ実際にインドはあった人の話なんです
アンゴジマーラっていうのは
でもわからない点は色々いくつかありますし
なんでそんなに人殺したかっていう
その理由は本当にそうか
あるいは別かな そこら辺いろいろわからない点はいくつかあるんですよ
ですから 学問的な論文もいろいろ書かれてはあります
そこで この彼が生まれる時は
この王様の刀やら槍やらね
そんなものだけではなくて
ベッドの下やいろんなところにはいろいろ置いている
もうもうとにかく鉄でなんかできているものであれば
もう何でもよかったっていうことで
その夜はね そういう意味をとって
もう刀やらものすごくピカッと光ったんだけど
別に誰にもそれで危険があったわけじゃないんですね
ただ光ってそれで終わった
まあそれで一瞬瞬間のことだからね
光って終わったと でも別にどうったことはないと
何も危険はなかったということで
彼にこのアヒンサカという名前を付けたんですね
アヒンサカっていうのは暴力を振るわないって意味なんですね
いわゆるすごく優しいという
ヒンサっていうのは暴力っていう意味で
アヒンサっていうのは非暴力ということ
ですから非暴力者っていうかね
誰にも迷惑かな すごい優しい人という意味の名前を付けたんですね
そこで彼がもう一応バラモンの家族の場合は
もう子供は男の子っていうのは早くも家から出すんですよ
で いくらかまあ 自分のことを自分でできるようになってくると
ブラマン人っていうのはあらゆることを勉強しなくちゃあかんですね
ものものすごいことを勉強しなくちゃいけない
だから一生はなかなか足らないというぐらいなんですね
暗記しなくちゃいけない量なんかはもう並じゃない
それで星占いだけじゃなくて
医学やらね 何から何まで勉強しなくちゃいけない
だから人一人で何年もかかる
ですから バラモンの中でみんな頑張ってますけど
途中で勉強をやめちゃいますからね
歳も取りますからね でも
たまに能力のある才能のある人が出たら
全部勉強して終わっちゃうんです
ですから 大体まあ歳になってくると出すんですよ
家からは もっと前に出すかと
わからないんですね で
まあ今このどんなエピソードでも
この学問の場所として考えたのはタクシーラなんですよ
今もインドにタクシーラという地方があります
もう昔もね このやっぱりかなりの優れている大学とかね
あったし 今もそういう跡もね
史跡もありますけどね
ナーランダ大学やらタクシーラ大学っていうのは有名なもんで
タクシーラ大学になってくる
それは仏教のお坊さんたちが作った大学なんですけど
大学のこれは大学みたいな感じで
このしっかりした学校にしたのはこのお坊さんたちなんですね
前は学校というよりは
この家 家 家ですよ ですから
各家でバラモン人がいて
その家で自分の学問を生徒たちに教える
その教えるバラモンたちが一箇所で
地方でかなりバカでかい建物ば作って
弟子たちが寝泊まりしているんだから
もう王様気分でいるんですね
ですから それを全部まとめて一つの学校にしようではないかということは
結構後でね お釈迦様亡くなってからかなり後でね
紀元ちょっと前ぐらいかなね
で 初めて発展していったんですけどね
昔は別にある一つの学校というわけじゃなくて
一人一人のバラモンが自分の家を学校にしているっていうことで
その場所としてタクシーラは非常有名なんですね
そこでこの子供もこのタクシーラに送っちゃうんですよ
このタクシーラ 今もタクシーラという同じ名前でその地方がありますけど
タクシーラという名前さえも
おそらくこのタッカっていうのは勉強ということで
ロジック 学問なんですよ
そういう場所なんですね
だから学問を習う場所という意味で
一応地方の名前までできているんですね
そこで学生は二種類いますね
学費払う学生と住み込んで勉強する学生っていうのは二種類いるんですね
まあ一応学問きちんと身についたければ
学費払うよりも住み込みで勉強した方がいいみたいんですよ
学費ちゃんと払う場合は
それほど先生はね そんなに真剣にっていうことはないんです
向こうはちゃんとお金払ってるんだから
お客さんだからね 今日は勉強したくないんですよって言ったら
ああそうですか はい わかります
明日にしましょうってことになるんですよ
住み込みはそうはできません
わがままは言えません
ですから 本当に勉強したい人は住み込み制度に入る
勉強したくない人々はもうちゃんと学費を払う
払ってお坊ちゃま気分で卒業して帰る
だから 王の息子たちは行く場合はどうせ学費払うんですよ
だから結局同じ学校で勉強するんだけど
学費を払わなかった貧しい友達をプロヒタの格に委任しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
だいたい王様がプロヒタでするの
そうやって一緒に学校にいた仲間一人か先輩の一人かなんですよ
でないと信頼できません
だけど どうせ子供の頃一緒に勉強する人々っていうのは
お互いに随分仲がよろしいし
裏切ることはないし ですから
バラモン系の人々は学費払わない
金はあるんだけど 王も息子たち同じ学校に入れちゃいますけど
やっぱり学費払うんですよ
だから学費払っちゃいますから
まあそれほどろくな勉強できないというかね
そこでアヒンサカというこの子供も学校に入れて
学費払うんじゃなくて
住み込み制度で学校に入れたんですね
その子は随分出来が良くて良くて
先生の家の仕事っていうのは
何から何まできちんとやる
で そこでももう言うと
すぐすごい活発的で まだまだ子供だからね
随分活発で 頼むことやら仕事やら
もう何でもかんでも存じにやる
と で もう言葉もすごいよろしいし
挨拶もよくできるし 行儀がいいしっていう
もう何から何までできてる子供なんですよ
だからかなり先生の気に入るんですよ
で ちょっと時間経つと
この子は何のことなく
あの先生のうちの家の子供のようにどんどんなってしまうんですね
愛情が生まれてくるんだから
外からもう学生として入った人なんですけど
まあちょっと時間経つと
もう学生のところじゃないんですね
この先生のなんか息子みたいになってしまっちゃうんですね
だから先生もいつでもこの子はそばにいて欲しがっちゃうし
よく呼ぶし もう だからこの住み込みなんですけど
先生と一緒に先生が住んでる奥さんと家族で住んでいる
その家で住むことになってしまったんですね
住み込み制度でも違います
だからたくさんいるんだから
そうやって寮みたいなものやらあったり
いろんなたくさんあります
そこらへん住んでるんですよ
それで先生は自分の奥さんと別な家があって
そちらに住んでいて その子だけ特別に一緒に先生の家族と一緒に寝泊まりしてご飯食べて勉強するようになってしまったんですね
そこで他の生徒たちがかなり嫉妬しちゃったんですね
このアヒンサカが来てからはね
なんか私たちはいないような感じだと
先生には見えないんだと
自分たちのことは とにかくこの先生とこいつを何とかして仲間割れにしなきゃダメやと
でなきゃ自分たちのことを先生先生は見ようともしないと
そこでこの生徒たちがもうどうしてこの二人を仲間割れしようかなと色々考えるんだけど
まあなんとかしようかなと
こちらいろいろ方法を書いてますけどね
何でしたっけ 例えばいろいろなんか勉強は失敗しましたとかね
もうなんとかそこら辺でからくりしようかなと思って
じゃあそういう方向どうですか？と
実際は覚えていないのに
なんとかカニングでもして先生騙してるんではないかと
そういうふうな何かしようではないかと
やっぱり無理やと それはすごい頭がいいんだと
それで無理やと だったら先生のお世話とかね
どこか何かサボったとかね
どこか間違ったとか そこら辺何かまあ何かちょっとした欠点
短所を探そうではないか
これ無理やと完璧に何もやってるんだからと
どう頑張ってもできませんと
朝ちょっと遅くなって起きるとかね
それぐらいもないんですね
だからこれは無理と そこで生まれとか家柄とかね
それはかなりやられるんですよ
今バラモン人だというんだけど
実はお母さんはバラモン人ではないよとかね
なんと言えばもう家柄がちょっと格が低いんですね
それだったら一緒にご飯食べたりすることできなくなったりって
これ無理ですよと もう正真正銘のバラモン人の中でも一番格の高いバラモン人の息子ですからね
これはもうどうどうしてももうできませんと
そこで一人だけなんかそこでやられる考える人がいて
え？一つの方法あるんだよと
先生の家の中で何かいい加減なことをやると
言っちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
先生に隠れて だから家の中にいる場合は
もう先生の監督外だから
先生は仕事中だからね
家に入ったら自分の息子と同じで
もう何やったってもいいということになっちゃうし
あまり気にしない そこら辺なんとかちょっと隙間があるんだよと
外ででは丸っきりできません
そこでこの弟子と先生がぴったし
もう何でもこなしているし
一旦仕事終わって勉強終わって
家に帰ってご飯食べて寝ようではないかというところになってくると
まあもう何のことなく自分の息子と同じことで自由なんですね
そこら辺しかないやということで
そこである日先生を呼んで
先生にこう言うんだよ
先生 ちょっと噂が流れているんだよと
どういう噂ですか？このアヒムサカが先生の家を汚してるんだと
そう言ったっても先生が怒るんですね
もう弟子たちに出ていけと
お前らこの身分の低い連中みんなっていう
身分の低いよりもうすごいきつい言葉言ってね
まあ出来の悪いね もう連中出ていけと
あの子供と私はもう仲が悪くしてやってもこれできませんと
すごく頭いいってことを
それよりこの弟子たち追い出したんだけど
また他の弟子のグループが来て同じことを言う
また他の弟子のグループが来て
先生にもそんなちょっと問題ですよと
もういろいろ別々なグループが来てくれて
もう先生に怒り困っちゃうんですね
もうグループが次から次へと
もう日にちが経って 先生にこのこの人はもう家を汚してるんだということを言うと
まあそれなりにかなりの体格のあるかなりの人でしたしね
この人が ですから もうあまりにも言われると
やっぱり自分の家を汚してる可能性あるんだよと
いうことにどんどん心が変わるんですね
だからこの細々弱々しい男の子でもなかったんですよ
すっごいもう体格があって
ものすごいもうもうハンサムで
誰でも圧倒されるぐらいのこの力だったんですよ
力と何て言いますか この見た目っていうのはね
誰目立ってもなんとなく惹かれてしまう
で そういう若者が自分の家でもずっと住んでるし
それでみんないろんなことを次から次へと言ってくると
先生もやっぱりどんどん心が変わっちゃうんですね
そこでもやがて先生はやっぱりこいつは殺さなきゃあかんと思っちゃうんですね
この弟子を 殺さなくちゃあかんと思ったって
もうこのタクシーラーの一番有名な先生なんですよ
いわゆるこの先生たちの中でもこのもう格がありますよ
王様から得られるこの一番上の国太子みたいな
その格を得ている人なんですね
それは一人しか得られないので
その人が死んだら次の人を選ぶんですよ
だからタクシー側のね
国太子である自分が自分の弟子一人殺したと言っちゃうとね
これはちょっとまずいと
そこでそんなことをしたらね
私はちょっとしたことで弟子を殺しちゃったということで
もう大変な不名誉になるし
それっきりで学校も閉鎖になっちゃいますよと
自分で生活できなくなるしね
これはやめましょうと
そこでとにかく学問を終わる
この子はもう卒業することになる
そこでこの住み込みの生徒たちも
お金がなくて住み込み制度にしているわけじゃないんです
どうせ学校に行くのはみんな金持ちなんですよ
一般人が行かないし バラモン人が王様の息子たちしか行かないし
だからみんな金持ちなんですよ
金持ちですけど 教育制度は 2つに分けてあって
学費を払う制度と住み込み制度の住み込み制度で
先生の仕事を奴隷みたいに
料理やら洗濯やらもう薪を割ることやら何からもう畑仕事やら何でもするんですよ
それで学生が自分の学費分は一生懸命仕事をしなくちゃいけない
田んぼの時期になったら
もう田んぼの仕事 稲刈りの時期になったら稲刈りをしなくちゃいけない
野菜を作るとこ行って野菜作らなくちゃいけない
それをもう持ってきて料理作らなくちゃいけない
それで先生のお世話全部やらなくちゃいけないとか
もうあらゆる仕事をしなくちゃいけない
それが子供が自分で学費をそういうふうに払っているんであって
で そういう制度なんですね
そこで一応学問を終わって卒業すると
一応決まりとしては親が先生にお金を払うんですよ
卒業する日は まあ感謝としてということで
子供育ててくれたんだと
で その場合は実際にお金のないバラモン人の息子だったら
もうなんとか感謝だけのことだから
ほんの何かちょっとしたことで感謝しててもよろしいし
本当に金持ちの息子だったら
もう全学費をいっぺんに払っちゃうんですよ
まあそういうことで ですから
この先生としては 学費払わない制度の生徒たちがもう学問終わったらどうするかともわからないし
とにかく仕事をさせる
いい制度で昔できたね
それで卒業生っていうのは
まあこれっていう文句のない人間として出来上がっちゃうんですね
だから子供だから知らないんですよ
親が後からお金くれるということさえも
自分で頑張らなくちゃってこと
一生懸命自分で頑張るでしょうに
それで競争も激しいんだから
自分が失敗してはいけないし
浅ねぼうしてはいけないし
もうそうするともう先生に追い出されるしね
だからとにかくこの生きる戦争で
もうとにかく生き延びるために
もうその技っていうのは何から何まで身につくんですよ
で 親も親でもう面倒見ようとはしないし
家に戻ることもできないし
学問が終わるまでは 大変厳しいんですね
卒業する時になってくると
先生に何かお礼をして家に帰ると
家に帰るともう親に言うこと何もない
もう一人前なんですね
ぴったしできてるんです
だから一応息子が家に帰ると
大体親がもう一つの儀式をやって
家の財産と権利は全て息子にもう渡すんですよ
学校から出てきたら 間もないうちに結婚と同時に
それで親がもう引退するという制度なんです
そこでこの人が勉強あったんだから
先生に何かこんなお礼するんだからね
その時は何とかするんだよって言って
このジャンガサハッサンガーティーヒティワッカミ
ジャンガっていうのは足なんですけど
足でも言うし 生き物って意味もあるしね
足を千本を いわゆる殺せということですね
と言いますよと そういうことを決めて
先生がこの子に あの じゃあ私には何も要りませんと
もう人を千人殺してくれと
人と言わない 足千本落としてほしいと
そこでその若者はマヤンアヒンサクレージャータ
私の家はアヒンサカって名前ですよと
非暴力という名前ですよ
まさかこれはできませんと
誰かに暴力振ることは
自分の家の名前までマヒンサカという名前ですよと
そこで先生はね 最後のお礼をしないと
それは決まり とにかく最後のお礼をしないと
先生に対してはね 受けた勉強は何一つも役に立たんよと
それまた怖いんですよ
勉強もいろいろあるんだから
呪文あるでしょうし まあ数学ぐらいは別に役に立たない
自分で勉強したものだからね
数学ぐらいはそう脅しに入りませんだけど
じゃあ呪文はどうしますかね
習ったブラックマジックやらね
いろいろあらゆることあるでしょうね
それはそう簡単にはいきませんだからね
治療方法のも半分マジックだからね
技術的なものだからね
それはもうちゃんと形式的に先生は教科出さない限りは
呪文だけ覚えてたっても機能しないという信仰なんですよ
だからあんたね もう最後のお礼しないとね
一生懸命勉強したものは全部役に立たなくなっちゃいますよ
そこで彼がどうしようもない
ハメられちゃいますね
バラモンの地へ流れているんだから
もう学問こそ命なんですね
それがもう絶対捨てたくない
学問身につかないと言っちゃうと
もう命を捨てたこととなっちゃうんですね
そういうことで はい わかりましたと
いろいろ槍やら刀やら弓やらね
有名な五つの武器があるんですよ
で それを持って森に入っちゃう
そこで森のもう入るところ
森の中やら森の出口やら
至るところで人が出入りする
止まってるけど そこらへんにいて
みるみる人を殺しちゃうと
何のことなく 殺しては捨てる
まあ何一つも盗らない
別に泥棒ではないんですよ
結局は 泥棒と言ってますけど
普通は人を殺して人の持ってるものを持ってきますし
この人そうじゃない まあいろいろ何か商売道具
商売品やら いろんなものを持って森通って人が行こうと言ったら
もう捕まってみんな殺しちゃう
そこであの品物やら全部そのまんまもう一つも手も触らない
ただ殺せにていると そこらへんみんな殺しちゃったんだから
じゃあ次のところに行くぞと
あっちもなんか人の声聞こえるんだから
そちらも行ってじゃあということで
そうやって殺しては殺しては行くと
そこでものすごい頭いい人だから
まあ計算ぐらいはもう何て言いますか
どったことないと すごい自信があるんです
だから何人殺すかと数えません
でも人殺しっていうのは
どちらでも経典じゃなくて
注釈書ではね 人殺しっていうのはそう簡単軽々くできるものじゃないんだと
かなり精神的には やっぱり殺される人のあの顔やらいろんなもの
みんな泣き叫ぶわ 殺さないでくれと言っちゃうわね
私に家族があるんだよ
なんてことするんですかとかね
千歳さん持ってでも命だけ助けて
いろんなこと言うでしょうに
そういうことをずっと自分の自分が見て聞いてますよ
本人が ですから いくら頭が良くても
そういう人殺しのような罪を起こしちゃうと
どんどん狂ってしまうんだと
[終始背景音楽]おかしくなって頭がバカになるんだよと
そこでこの人は ただ単に人は殺しては行って
他のところに行って殺しては他のところへ行って殺す
それだけで何やってるかと自分でわからなくなってくるんですね
そこでもう計算忘れちゃったんだよ
何人殺したか そこで考えたのは
ではあの数えられませんだから
人を殺すてますから 人を殺したら指１本取りましょうと行って
殺した人の指１本取っちゃう
指は小さいんだから運べるしね
また指１本取って また指
そこで指もそんなにも重ねるとちょっと大きいんだから
どこかに置いておく ブルの中で
置いとくのはいいんだけど
これ誰かに食べられちゃうんですね
森だから そこで今何人
今日で何人でしょうかといって置いたいろんなところで隠しておいた指なんか指がない
動物たちに食べられちゃって
考えたのは まあしょうがない
自分のは首は遅くて まあ持ち運べないとあかんということで
色々だからとる取るとる指をつなげてつなげてつなげて
もう持っていくんですね
どんどん立派な大変な家督のね
王様でも尊敬するぐらいの家柄の息子で
息子は息子なりにものすごい出来のいい人でしたしね
もう一つも一言葉も言いたいことはなかったし
そういう完璧な子なんでしたけどね
どんどんどんどんどんどん堕落していっても
右も左もわからない ただ人を見たら殺すしか頭にないんだ 「
あ 人だ じゃあ殺します」というぐらい
それしか頭の中にない
人間っていうのは 彼にとってはもう何者でもなく
ただ自分のゲームの相手だけなんですね
人間は人間に見えなくなっちゃったんですね
ですから 森に入ってこの狩りをやっている人々と同じく
あの まあ殺してはもう自慢に
イギリス人やらね よくやってるでしょうに
この森に入って 鹿やらトナカイやら色んな動物を殺して
首をきっとカットして持ってきて
これは剥製なんとかにして壁にかけてるでしょ
こんなバカでかい動物を殺したんだぞとかね
そういう思考になってしまったんですね
このストーリーほどいろいろもう研究したり
ですから この言葉もあまりにも古くてわからない言葉もたくさんあるし
ですから まあ意訳と意訳ではなくて
このもういろんなテキストがたくさんあったんですよ
かなり大事にしてたストーリーなんだから
大変難しくなっちゃうんですね
あまりにも使い過ぎのストーリーですからね
わからない言葉っていうのが出てきます
まあとにかく彼の名前がもうアングリマーラになってしまったんですね
アングリってのは指 マーラっていうのはこの輪というね
まあ一応マーラっていうのは首にかけるかなり大きい輪って
あの 今日本で使ってるちょっとしたチェーンとは違います
マーラはかなり大きいんですよ
首にかけたって大体膝ぐらいになるようなネックレスもあるし
まあおへそのところまでやるネックレスもあるし
あるいは大きなネックレスはもう２つに折って首にかける場合もあるし
そういうもうだからもうネックレスやと言ったらほんのちょっと小さいっていうことではありません
まあこの場合はネックレスになりませんだけど
ただの首輪なんですけど
ですからまあ首にかけてはいたんですね
そこでサンバンアランニャンニッサンチャラン
ニッサンチャランアカシ
ダールワーディーナガッタヤアランニャンガントゥサマットーナーマナッティ
だから誰一人も森には入らなくなっちゃったんですね
入ったら終わりだから
人の声 音を聞いたら行ってすぐ殺しちゃいます
もう何もこともない この人の頭にはそれしかないんです
そういうことだから怖いんですよ
泥棒でもそれほど怖くないんですよ
泥棒でもそこら辺この薪を拾いに来た人にでも殺そうってことないんだからね
泥棒だったら金を持って商品を持って歩く人ら待ち伏せをして捕まると
その場合は商人たちもそれなりの戦える人々は警備を持ってきますからね
そう簡単ではない この人の時は人であれば十分です
すぐ殺しちゃう ですから
かなり怖い 誰も安心ということはない
金持ちはだけは危険で
貧しい人はどうったことない
そんなことない 貧しいかろうが金持ちであろうが
人間だったらダメっていうことで
そこで森に人が入らなくなっちゃうと
この人はもう村に行く
村に行って 夜はもう家々から入って
もう家に入ったらもうドア破って家に入って
みんな殺して指を持って帰る
次の家に行ってみんな殺して指を持って帰ると
だから一日で村は村でなくなっちゃうんですよ
夜は歩けるぐらいは歩いて指を取って帰る
だから一日で村一つ潰すことはできませんだから
結構時間かかるでしょうしね
人を殺して また指を取って
もう次の家にまた距離もありますからね
そういうことだから もうあまりにも恐怖感で
そこでみんな逃げて逃げて逃げて
あっちこっちからもう逃げて逃げていくんですよ
逃げる場所といえば このどんどんガームからニガマに逃げて
森から大きな村から大きな村に逃げて
大きな村ところからこの県に逃げたりとかね
そこからまた逃げなくちゃいかんですね
それで結局結局もう首都の方へ大勢の難民たちがもう入っちゃうんです
行くとこないんだから
戻ったらやられちゃう
殺される ですから 王様のもう町の方にものすごい人がザーッと入るんですよ
みんな難民で 何ですか？って言ったら
こういうすごい恐ろしい泥棒がいるんだよ
どうにも命はもう守ることはできないんだと
だから来る来る人々は泣きながら
このアングリマーラという人がいて人殺すんだよとかね
そこでこの話を聞くと
このバラモン人がおそらくこれ自分の息子ではないかと
もう名前変わってますけどね
そこまでやるといえば自分の息子ではないかと
もう一応思っちゃうんですね
もう知らない もう今は
言ってこのお母さんにも言うのはおそらくね
私は思うには あのアングリマーラという泥棒はもううちの子やと
で 奥さんに言うんですよ
アングリマーラという名前の大泥棒が現れてますけど
あいつはもう他でもなく君の息子アングリマーラだと思いますよと
今は王様がこのアングリマーラを捕まえるためにもう出て行ったと
そこでお母さんにこう言うんですね
ガッチャサミプッタンメーガヘットゥアーエーヒティ
そんなこと言った途端
この奥さんが だったら早く出て行けと
行って息子連れてこいよと旦那に言うんですよ
私の息子早く連れて来いと
王様が行って王様に捕まる前にと
そこでできませんと そんなことは
そこで父親は断る こういう私が行って息子を戻そうと思っちゃうと
私はこの全国民から怒られるんだよと
それだけじゃなくて 自分の嫌がる他のバラモンたちみんな私のことはね
まあ何者かとね 思われるんだよ
そこで王様っていうのはね
私のことを大変信頼しているしね
それで私は王様を裏切ったことになるんだよと
みんなに言われると 自分の家の言うことを聞いたんだよと
この全国民を裏切って
王様を裏切って 知識人バラモンたちを裏切って自分の家内の話を聞いた
バカもんやと 私は笑い者になるんだよと
これだけはできませんと
いくら息子でもと でもマートハダヤンパナムドカンホーティ
そんなこと言ったっても
母の心っていうのはもう効かないんだ
そんな理屈は 母は息子のことは可愛い
ただそれだけ もう人殺しであろうが何であろうが関係ないという
効かないんだと タスマサーアーハ
それで彼女こう言うんですね
アハンパナガントマヒャンプッタンアーネッサーミ
ニッカンタタンディワサン
お母さんが「あ そう だったら私が行って私の子供を連れてくる」
そこまで言うんだったらと
まあ子供のことかわいくてかわいくて
もう自分で行っちゃうんですね
タンディワサンジャバガヴァパッチューサメーローカンオーローケントアングリマーランディスワ
その日 お釈迦様が朝早く起きて
今日は誰が悟りを開ける能力ある人がいるんでしょうかと
毎日見るんですよ そこで誰か誰かお釈迦様のもうアンテナには入ります
いたらそちらに行ってお釈迦様は説法して
まあ悟るように導くんですよ
この日もお釈迦様は朝早くも今日は誰が能力者がいるんでしょうかと見たら
アングリマーが入ったんですね
今よりは昔はお釈迦様は簡単でしたね
お釈迦様悟りを開ける能力ある人にさえしか説法してないんだからね
だからみんな悟ったんです
インドであれほどたくさんいたのに
お釈迦様は自分で人を選んで選んでいったんです
だから私もわからなかったんですよ
なぜお釈迦様の説法を聞いた人はみんな悟ったんですかと
こういうことでしたから
それだったらね 楽でしょうね
資格者を選ぶんですね
私は毎朝テレビをつけて見るんだけど
一人も入りません この人なら悟るけどと
今はテレビしかないんだから
マイガトゥエータッソッティバディッサティ
お釈迦様こう思うんです
私が行ったならば あの若者には幸福になりますと
あの若者が そこで人も一人もない森の中で
人がもうみんな逃げてるんだからね
私は四行 何か四行の詩
歌 ガーターですね 偈を喋ったら
それだけでこの人は出家するんだと
悟り目開くんだと それぐらい頭がいいんだと
もし私が行かなかったらどうなるかというと
マータランアパラジッワアヌッダラニーヨバビッサティ
もし私が行かなかったら
この母親も出ているんですよ
母親殺すんだと だからこの人にも人間見えないんですよ
人間見えますけど 人間というのはサッと殺すものであって
こんにちはというものじゃないんです
人間だったら殺して指一本取るだけで十分です
こんにちは とか どこに行くんでしょうかとか
何の用事があるんでしょうかとかね
私の森になんかお前らなんか入るな
入ったら殺そうとそんな話する必要じゃないんです
人間だったら殺して指輪取るだけのことで
だから縄張りとかそんなのはない
そういうところにこの女の人が行ったら
当然女も子供誰でも殺すんだから
もう殺されますよ それで母親を殺したらもう終わりですね
仏教では それは仏教の話で
母親父親を殺しちゃうと
その人にはもうもう悟れない
いくら踏ん張っても次には地獄に落ちるんです
どんな理由があっても
母父殺しちゃうと もうこれは重罪なんですね
それで一千年地獄にいなくちゃいけないんで
阿鼻地獄にまた決まってもいるし
阿鼻地獄というと 日本ではなんかすごい恐ろしい地獄やと思っちゃいますけど
そういうことでもないんだ
阿鼻地獄の寿命が短いんですよ
アビチと呼んでパーリ語で
日本語で何発音かちょっとわからない
この麻原の人々もなんかみんなに脅したでしょ
なんとか地獄に落ちるんだそうとかね
阿鼻地獄 うん それはパーリ語のアビチというね
名前なんですね で そんなにこの麻原のグループが怖くって怯えた
で それはもうわからないんだから
そういうふうになっているのであって
まあ両親殺ったら阿鼻地に阿鼻地に落ちますよっていうのは一般的な言い方なんですよ
でも実際に仏教ではこの地獄の寿命
天国の寿命とかね そういう分析ちゃんとあるんですよ
地獄としてはすごいレベル低いのところなんですけど
この太陽系とこの地球の寿命と繋げているんですよ
システムは ですからもう太陽系崩れると地獄も崩れちゃいます
だからそれほど時間長いというわけじゃないんです
1光年でもう崩れちゃいます
まだ別な地獄あるんですよ
この物質的な 我々のこの世界とは関係ない
その場合はものすごいもう何光年も苦しまないからいなくちゃいけない
これは壊れませんだから世界そのものが
だから阿鼻地阿鼻地獄だけはこの普通の世界と何らかの関係あるみたいですね
なんでアビチという名前をつけたんですかというところははっきり定義はないんですけどね
だからこの隙間がないように生命がいるんだという意味意味だそうですね
かなりいるみたい そこで普通の罪を犯す人々っていうのは
まあもっと軽い軽い地獄に落ちちゃいます
で 軽い軽い地獄に落ちるんですが
まあ一旦地獄に落ちたらね
心は暗いばっかしだからね
地獄から抜け出すこと難しいんですよ
だから地獄に一旦落ちたら
この何万年も苦しんでるでしょ
苦しんで苦しんで寿命になってくる
そうすると死ぬんですよ
死んだら次に生まれ変わるために次の思考でしょ
もう地獄に苦しんで苦しんでて人だから
全然明るい思考なんかありっこないんですよ
結局怒り憎しみばっかしなんですよ
だから次の生まれ変わりもそこら辺になる
それでまたもう何万年も苦しんだところで
もう長い人生でしょうに
もう続けてかなり心に思考がもう染み付いてるんですよ
また明るい思考っていうのはまだできないんですよ
だから一旦地獄に落ちたら
人間が過去で虫なる過去でやっていた悪行っていうのはいくらでもあるんだから
いくらでもありますよ
過去で犯した罪というのは
だからもういくらでも地獄にいられる
だから一旦地獄に落ちて
地獄から出て行った人っていうのはなかなかこのないんですよ
例えばインドの世界にいたっても
この超能力とかあった人々いますけどね
実際に だからそういう超能力あった人々でも
地獄地獄を観察しちゃうと
落ちたのは落ちたんだけど
地獄から立ち上がって普通の世界に戻ったっていうケースは見当たらないというかね
それで地獄に落ちたら一旦終わりだというふうに言ってしまっちゃうんですね
仏教はそんなことはないんだ
終わりっていうことはないんだぞと
地獄も普通の世界と同じだよ
寿命終わったら終わりますよと
と言いながらも やっぱり心の法則っていうのは
我々長い間した思考は続けてやるんだからね 10
年悪い考え方を持っていっちゃうと
もうずっとそれで死ぬまで同じ考え方でいってしまっちゃうんですね
それがすごく恐ろしいんだと
だから地獄に一旦落ちちゃうと
もうもう先がなくなっちゃうというかね
そこで地獄から立ち上がれるのは
例えば人間でずっといいことをしていて
たまたま失敗する どうせ人間だから
たまたま何か悪いことをしてしまっちゃう
それで死ぬ時 ああ 失敗してまた悪いことをしちゃったと思い出しちゃうと
思考が暗いんだから地獄に落ちちゃうんですね
落ちた瞬間でびっくりするんですよ
なんで自分が地獄にいるんですかと
なんで苦しくなくちゃいけない羽目になったんですかと
そこで思考は綺麗な思考をしていたんだからね
そこで思い出す いや 別に私はあんなちっぽけな罪を犯しただけで地獄に落ちたんで
でも結構自分なりにはいい人間でいたんではないかと
と思っちゃうと思考が変わってて
それで終わるんですよ
それで地獄からもう死んでしまうんちゃう
地獄で死んじゃう もう思考が変わったんだから
死んじゃって他のいいところに生まれ変わっちゃう
そういう人でない限りは私ももうちょっともうわからないんですね
だから仏教というのはもういつでも明るい思考でね
慈しみの思考で生活するしか
人間にはもう安全な生き方はないんだよと
簡単に人を憎しみ 簡単に食らう暗い思考を持つ
それはとんでもない話だと
冗談で遊びじゃないんだと
心は そういうことで このお釈迦様がこの人は母を殺しちゃうと
もうどうにもならん もう長い間もうもう人を殺してきたんだから
もう思考はもうもうもうガタガタで
もう何も直らないぐらいに
でもちょっとだけ見込みがある
小さい時から卒業するまではもう完璧な真面目に生きていたんだからね
お釈迦様はそこら辺はちょっと期待している
なかなか頭のいい子やと
もうちょっと今はちょっと悪いことしてるだけで
それはちょっと抜けちゃいければいいんじゃないかなと
でもそれで母を殺しちゃうと
もうもうお手上げと だからこれで
お釈迦様とお母さんがもう競争するんで
結局は 先にどちらが会うかと
このアングリマーラに
母も王様が来る前に 他の人が来て息子を殺す前に息子を連れてきたいという気持ちなんですけど
結局自分は殺される お釈迦様はこいつは母を見たらすぐ殺すんだから
それより先に自分が会わなくちゃいけないということで森に入るんですね
そこまで注釈書の話を一旦停止して
ア
タコーバガヴァープッバンナサメアンニワーセトワパットチーバラマーダーヤサーワッティンピンダヤパービシーサーワッティアンピンダヤチャリットワパッチャバッタ
ンピンダヤパータパティッカンツーセーナーサナンサンサーメットワパットチーバランアーダーヤエーナチョーローアングリマーラーテーナッダーナマッガンパティパッジー
アタコーバガヴァー その時お釈迦様がプッバンナサメアン午前中ニワーセトワ衣を着て
パットチーバランアーダーヤ鉢と
もう一つ衣がありますね
肩にかける衣 それを持ってパッチャバッタン
サーワッティンピンダヤパービシー
斎場の方に托鉢に出かけて
サーワッティアンピンダヤチャリットワ斎場で托鉢を終わってパッチャバッタン食事後
ピンダパータパティッカンと戻ってきて
ピンダ托鉢から戻ってきて
セーナーサナン サンサーメとは自分の部屋を片付いたんですね
お釈迦様の部屋をご自分で
普通は阿難尊者のお仕事なんです
お釈迦様は昼のご飯を召し上がって
デートの精舎に戻って
お釈迦様の部屋をちょっと片づくっていうかね
畳むんですよ そこでパッタチーワランガでまた鉢と自分の個人的な
今だったらみんなカバン持って出かけるでしょうし
昔はもう鉢持って番目枚目の衣持って出ていくんです
またそれだけ また水越しを持っていきますけど
それぐらい持って もう鉢を肩にかけて
衣もその上にかけちゃって
もうただ手ぶらで出かける
荷物は持ってなかったんですね
個人的に使う荷物いろいろあるんだけど
それは寺のもので 個人のものじゃないんですね
ですから どんな出家お坊さんでも
寺に住んで寺を出る時は
全部荷物をちゃんと片付けて
元の場所に戻って出かけなくちゃいけない
自分のものって何もない
自分のものっていうのは鉢だけ
ところもだけ それを持って帰ると
でお釈迦様もこの比丘たちに決めた決まりを
お釈迦様はやっぱり何のことなく守るというか
やるんですよ でもいつでもやるわけじゃないんです
あれ特定の お釈迦様の場合
特定の意味があるんですよ
お釈迦様は托鉢から戻ってくると
どうせあのまた戒律の決まりがあるんですよ
先生と弟子の場合は 先生が托鉢に出かけると
托鉢に出かける前に必要なものは全部弟子が用意しておかなくちゃいけない
そこで先生では托鉢に出ようかなと衣を着ると
弟子がちゃんと鉢を持っているんです
鉢を肩にかけたら 次枚目の衣をあげる
で これを自分で肩にかけて出かける
それで先生が托鉢して帰るときは
もう弟子が先に帰って座るところで水なんか汲んで置いておき
用意しておく まあそういうことだから
先生は付きっきり弟子を育ててるんだからね
だから大体先生格の人々
お坊さんたちはもうあれこれとやる必要はなくなっちゃうんですよ
お釈迦様の場合 お釈迦様はものすごい忙しいんだからね
この個人的なことは何一つもできないし
ですから 全部阿難尊者がね
朝から晩までもうずっと付きっきりで面倒を見ているんです
なのに時々お釈迦様は自分で部屋の掃除と片付けをする
それ自分で手を出したら
もう他のお坊さんたちも阿難尊者も知ってます
これはちょっと違うと
例えば座っていたもうまあ作務もなかったと思いますけど
座っていたところの布でも
お釈迦様自分でこうやって畳んでおいたら
これちょっと気をつけろということになる
これが何か違うと その時は阿難尊者も顔出せない
顔も合わせない 外でじっと待っている
なぜか お釈迦様その場合は誰にも口もきかないで出てくるんですよ
どこに行くかとも言わない
それでお釈迦様ちょっと待ってくださいと言える人間も天国も神々も誰もいません
かなりのもうブッダですからね
ちょっと待ってくださいと言える人間はいません
国王もできません だから阿難尊者なんかもう弟子だからね
どうしても怖くて言えないしね
ですから みんなもう何もできなくて
挨拶も何もできなくてじっと待っているお釈迦様はなんのことなくさーっと出ていく
だから そうやってまるっきり一人で
誰にも言わないで出かけて出かける場合っていうのはあるんですよ
その場合に限って お釈迦様はもう自分一人で部屋の片付けをする
そこはまたみんなよくわかっていることで
誰も お釈迦様私がやりますっていう
その失礼なことはしません
すごいこの出家の世界って
この昔今はないんですけど
このしきたり厳しいというのは微妙なところで計算しなきゃ大変なんです
私も若い頃すごい大変なんですよ
ほんの微妙なところで間違ってはあかんですよ
まあですから お釈迦様の場合でも
ほんの微妙に見えたら
お釈迦様ご自分で手を出した
伸ばしたなと 伸ばしたなと思ったら
もう気をつけろと みんな寂しいんです
もうお釈迦様はいつ帰るかわからない
何ヶ月間かかるかわからない
何年かかるかもわからない
あるいはその日で帰る可能性もある
俺わかりません どうやって聞くんですかね？聞けません
そういうことで それでも一回
二回は子供がいて邪魔をしたというケースはあるんです
子供そんなこと気にしませんだからね
何か喋りたければ行って喋っちゃうということは
その時お釈迦様も何のことなく
その場合は相手にしてあげる
それ以外 この普通常識ある人間であろうか
神々であろうか 誰ももう前には来ない
で この場合もお釈迦様は自分で片付いて出かけるんですよ
ジェーナチョーロアンゴリマーロ
このアンゴリマーラがいるところにテーナアッダハナマッガンパティパッジャッジン
アッダハナマッガンというのは
このアンゴリマーラがいるこの町
道に 道路に入りましたと
アンゴリマーラいるところに行くために
そこでアッダサースンコウゴーパーラカパスパーラカカッサカアマパダーヴィノ
バガワンタジェーナチョーロアンゴリマーロテーナアッダハナマッガンパティパンナ
そこでこの一方通行みたいな感じで
アンゴリマーラが住んでいるその地方に行く道があって
そこに釈迦様が入ってしまって
ずっと前へ歩く そこら辺の村です
お釈迦様は町に住んでいましたから
サイジョウに そこら辺でこの人々見えるんですね
お釈迦様出かけていくのを
一人で ゴーパーラカ 牛飼いの人々
パスパーラカ 他の動物ですね
カッサカ 百姓さんたち
農耕わっている人々 パダーヴィノ
他の用事で行ったり来たりしている人々
みんなお釈迦様がもう何のことなく
もうずっとこの行ってはいけない道歩いてるんですね
危険に ものすごい危険な道で
ここでみんなマースサマナエータンマッガンパティパッジ
みんな言うんですよ ブッダであることはあまりわからないんですけど
シャモンであることだけは知ってますね
シャモンというのは出家だからね
だからシャモンはその道で行ってはいけませんよと
エータスミンサマナマッゲチョーロアンゴリマーロナーマロッドーローヒタパーニ
前に聞いた同じ文章 この道で行っちゃったらものすごい恐ろしくて
もう血まみれで 手が血まみれで
もう血に塗れてて もうとんでもない恐ろしい泥棒がいて
もう村丸ごと壊しちゃうと
ソーマヌッセワディッタワディッタアンゴリーナマーランダーレティ
彼がもう指の首輪までかけてるんだと
エータンニサマナマッガンダサビプリサヴィーサティムビプリサ
人間がこの十人グループでグループであろうか
二十人のグループであろうか
三十人のグループであろうか
四十人のグループであろうか
みんなこのグループを組んでいくんですよ
一人ですから 向こうは
じゃあ十人ぐらいだったらあいつを潰せる
倒せるでしょう もうダメですよ
四十人で行ったとしてもね
みんな怯えちゃうんですよ
だってもう人殺ししか頭にないんだから
誰でも心がやっぱり怖いんですよ
私は可愛いんだから もうなんとか優しく親切に
これ全然ないんだからね
殺すんだからね パティパッジャンって殺すんだと
そこで 四十人で行ったってもアンゴリマーラが殺しますよと
アンゴリマーラに殺されないわけじゃないんですから
行くなよと言うんですね
お釈迦様はトゥンニブーとアガマシ
聞いてないような感じで前に進む
周りにまあ行くなよ どこに行くんですか？このシャモンはアホではないかと
いろいろ言うでしょう
おそらく 行ったら殺されるんだよと
お釈迦様が聞いてないふりでまた進む
また他のところでまた人々言う
三回も そこでお釈迦様は何のことなく進んで道を歩む
アッドサコーチョロアンゴリマーラバガワンタンドゥーアトアーガッチャンタン
アンゴリマーラさんがお釈迦様を見たんですね
遠くから だって他の人間はいないところだから
ディスワネータドーシ
このようなことを考えたんだと
アッチャリアンワタボー
なんて不思議でしょうかと
アッブタンワタボー なんてありえないことですかと
イマンイマガンダサピプリサヴィーサティンピプリサ
この道はもう十人組で
グループで二人グループで
三十人グループで四十人グループで来るんだよと
これは五十人グループでも来るんだよと
いくら来たって私は捕まっちゃいますよと
私の手の中に入りますよ
アタジャパナアヤンサマノーエーコアドゥティヨ
パサイヘマンニェアーガッチャティ
なのに アタジャパナというのは
なのにアヤンサマノー
このシャモンがエーコ一人で
アドゥティヨ もう二番目の誰もいない
自分一人で パサイアマンチェ
なんか偉そうに威張って俺は怖いものないぞという感じで
アーガッチャティと来るんではないかと
パサイアマンニェというのはそういうこと
俺にとって何が怖いものないぞと
そんな態度でっかくて
よく一人で来るんだよと
五十人来ても何の意味もないのにと
まあまあいいわよ 殺してやるぞと
からきも そんな威張って来てもね
殺してやると 思っちゃうんですね
そこでアンゴリマーラはさっさと準備するんですね
アセチャンマ 刀と体を守るためのなんとかありますね
それとそれからダヌカラーパン
弓と矢を入れている それは全部一応武装するんですね
だからこのおそらくこのアンゴリマーラがかなりこの森の中のことを知っていたでしょうやと思いますけどね
なんで十人でも一発で殺されるかというと
結局前から攻撃しないんですよ
四十人も行くのはアンゴリマーラが出てきたら四十人もう囲まって殺しちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
アンゴリマーラそうじゃないんですよ
四十人よく見えるんで
あちらから来るんだよと
言ったら ゆっくりのんびり自分が準備をして後ろから来て攻撃するんだ
そこは誰も知らない だから森の生活だから
足音でも何もわからんでしょうに
聞こえないでしょうに
それ上手になったと思いますけどね
すんなり後ろから来てさっさと人殺しちゃえば
もうみんな驚いて怯えちゃうでしょうね
まあそれその瞬間でも殺されますから
いくらなんでも もう誰ももう準備できてないでしょうに
あっち向いてこっち向いてくるでしょうかというふうにいるだけでも
後ろからやられる ですから
お釈迦様にしても まあ後ろから攻撃するんですよ
だから後ろからお釈迦様をもう追っかけていくんですね
アタコバカワタタールーパンイッダアビサンカーランアビサンカーシ
そこでお釈迦様はある神通を起こすんですね
このストーリーの場合は
やっぱりこの神通というか
超能力がないと成り立たないんですよ
だからお釈迦さんに何も能力がなかったということはちょっと成り立たない
他のところは超能力なんかなくてもいいんじゃないかというところあるんですけどね
このストーリー自体は仏典の中でも確固たる
もうすごい人気のある
有名である もうかなり研究されているストーリーで嘘じゃないんですよ
この実際にそういう人がいましたし
八十人のお坊さんの中で
阿羅漢の中で一人でしょうしね
だから出来上がった話ではないんです
経典にそのまま淡々とストーリーも出ていてね
注釈書で出てくる神通力の話だったら
まあいいわよ しましょうということでもいいんですけど
これは経典の中でも出てくるものだからね
ある神通というかね ある神通力を超能力というかね
それを起こすんですね
もう大したことではない
もう我々考えているようなところ
大胆なバカでかいスケールの神通力っていうことじゃなくて
すごいこの誰も気が付かないようなことをするんですよ
それはどういうこと？アタチョルアングリマナバガワンタンパカティアイガッチャンタンサッバッタメーナガッチャントナサッコーティサンパップニトン
神通力は お釈迦様は普通に歩く
いわゆる私は普通に歩くんだけど
アングリマーラが全力で走ってきたっても
私のところに近寄れないようにという
アングリマーラ走るは走るは走るは走る
お釈迦様は普通に歩いている
でも近寄れない それだけのことで
見たても誰も気がつかない
一人が一生懸命走って
一人が普通に歩いている
なかなか近寄れないだけのことなんです
だからそういう神通力ってどのようにするかっていうことはね
私は超能力者ではないんだからわかりませんですけどね
超能力者のところから
もう私の説法にまでクレームつけていますから
で そのやり方なんですけど
このサマーディの力で
この第4 善上のサマーディに入って
この地面を縮んでもらうんですよ
それをこっちもチースイカーフの瞑想を実践してるんだったら
そういうそれほどの難しい出来事ではありません
心で決めれば チースイカーフのフでしょうに
フをジーッてなくなって
もう縮むんですよ だからこの地球にしたっても
この空間 間が全部潰れちゃうと
野球ボールぐらいでしょう
大きさは 今大きいんだけどね
隙間があるんですよ 全部この原子の隙間
隙間がなくなっちゃえば
最初大きさがないんですよ
その場合は地だけ それは実際には存在しません
で まあそれ まあ心の働きで
これは縮んでもらうんですよ
そうすると お釈迦様一歩足を一歩進んでも
他の人々にとってはこれは 100メートルぐらいの距離があるんですよ
だから この大きなスポンジをそのままどこかに入れるか
こうやってじっと縮んでるるかっていうことなんですね
スポンジをぎゅっと縮んじゃうと小さな穴に入ります
そのまま入れようと思っちゃうと場所が取ります
だから地球はちょっとスポンジのような感じで
ちょっと縮んでもらうんです
縮んでもらったら これはこの
その心の働き出した人にのみ縮むんです
他の人には縮まない だからお釈迦様がゆっくりのペースで歩くんだけど
進んだ距離はすごいんですよ
それがなかなか普通の人の目には入りません
普通の人には見えるってこともできません
だからかなり早く 早いんですよ
かなり早いんだけど 実際の歩く方
歩いてるお釈迦様を見ると普通に歩いている
だからお釈迦様が地球をね
スポンジのようにじっと縮んで一歩前に進んで
また後ろから来るアングリマーラはまた元に戻っているんだから
これ競争になりませんね
いくらなんでも アングリマーラはこういうずるいことをやっているとわからないんですね
そこでアングリマーラは後ろからとにかく走る
いくらなんでも人間の力
体力で限界あるんだからね
もう走れなくなっちゃうんですね
こう考えるんですね アッチリエンワタブアブタンガタワ
これまた不思議やと 私は昔はアハンプッベハッティンピダワンタン
象が走ったってもアヌパティットアガンナアミ
すぐ追い越して捕まります
アッサンピダワンタン
馬に乗って走ったら 私は後ろから走ってきて追い起こしちゃいます
でもとにかく攻撃は後ろからなんですよ
前からじゃないんですね
ラタンピダーワンタンアヌパティットアガンナアミ
車に乗ってみんな逃げちゃっても
私は後ろから行ってすぐ追い起こしたって捕まりますと
ミガンピダーワンタン
他の動物に乗って行ったっても同じこと
でも取りますと アタパナハン
それなのにイマンサマナ
このシャモンはパクってやがっちゃった
普通に歩いてるだけですよ
サッバタメナガッチャンと全力で歩く私にナサッコメサンパープニンと
なかなか近寄ることはできないんではないかと
もう息切れですよ もう歩けない
それでティトはタッタマンマでバガワンタンエタジお釈迦様にこんなことを言ったんですね
ティッティッタサマナ
シャモン待てと もう何か日本から帯びたんでしょうかね
日本だったら追い置かす場合は待て待て言うでしょうに
待てるわけじゃないんですけど
生きてる連中はね もう何かご褒美でもくれるんだったら待ってあげたっていいんだけど
これ捕まえちゃってて
あれあんまり意味がないんですけどね
ティッタサマナーティ
シャモン待ちなさいよ
待ちなさいよと言うんですね
そこでお釈迦様はティトアハン
私は待ってるんですけど
これは止まってるんですけど
トンジャティッタ お前は止まったらどうですかと
そうやってサッと言うんですよ
この この仏教のこの昔はね
今は嫌われるんですけど
この昔はなぜこの すぐ人の心に真理が入るかと
この言葉の使い方なんです
刺したようにサッと言うんですよ
そうすると心が変わるんです
だからストップしなさいということで
おそらく私は止まってますよ
お前は止まりなさいよ
その時点でこのアンゴリマーラがもうもうもう走れない
息切れで止まっている
お釈迦様は全然歩いていて
全然止まってない この喋ってる時でもお釈迦様は止まりません
それでも歩いている 私は止まってるんですけどと言っていながら歩いている
だからそこら辺で人のこの興味と知恵をね
引き起こしてもらうんですよ
そこでアンゴリマーラがアタコチューラスアンゴリマーラセーダすると彼がこう思っちゃいますね
イメコサマナサッキャプッティアサッチャバーディノサッチャパティパンナ
このシャモンたちっていうのはサッキャ
サッキャプッティア 聞いたことがあるみたい
もう釈迦の弟子たちやと
サッキャプッティアっていうのは釈迦の息子たちっていう意味なんですけど
弟子っていう意味なんですね
これ このシャモンたちはもう釈迦の弟子ですよと
サッチャバーディノ もうなかなかのもんで
厳密にこの真理 事実を語る
絶対嘘言わない しっかりした人々やと
サッチャパティパンナ
真理の道を歩んでるんだと
もうインチキ嘘何ひとつ影もないんだ
アタチャパナアヤンサマナ
なのにこのシャモンが
自分が知ってるシャモンたちはもう釈迦の息子たちで
きっちりしっかりと事実を語って事実を実践しているんだよと
なのにこのシャモンはブッダであることを知らない
このシャモンはもう嘘つきやと
ガッチャンエワアハンティト
ガッチャンエワ 歩きながら止まってるよと言うんではないかと
ティトアハンアンゴリマーラ
トンジャティッタ お前止まれと
何やこれと 嘘ではない
ヤンノーナーハンイマンサマナンプッチェヤンケ
聞かなくちゃあかんと
これは やっぱり今まで人を見たら殺す相手だけで殺すターゲットだけ
今疲れて疲れて疲れてもう体に体力はない
残ってるのは頭の能力だけなんですね
いくら頭狂っていたっても
体に疲れると運動するともう脳がまた整理するんですよ
ですから いくらか脳はもう回転し始めているし
その瞬間なんですね だから体がギリギリ疲れ果てるまでお釈迦様
この人をもう歩かせちゃうんですよ
もう倒れそうになって
そこで体力ある人だから
もうあと人殺ししか頭に頭動かなかったでしょうね
だからもう体力のギリギリのところになってくると
また脳が開発 脳が回転し始めて
体の心体にそれはもう諦めちゃうんですね
だから本人もすぐやられちゃったんで
この罠に 殺すことってちょっと忘れちゃって
これ聞かなくちゃあかんかった
なんだこの嘘はと だから興味がそれちゃったんですね
聞いてみようと では そこら辺で終わります
[効果音]